France 24 et RFI présente
[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
sur France 24 et Radio France
Internationale pour ici l'Europe une
rentrée sous le signe de l'économie avec
le G20 et de la diplomatie avec
l'Assemblée des Nations Unies qui
s'ouvrent mardi alors pour parler de
l'Union européenne dans la tourmente sur
ses chapitres où elle voulait porter une
voix et un modèle singulier nous avons
le plaisir de recevoir aujourd'hui
Pascal Lamy bonjour je rappelle que vous
étiez commissaire européen au commerce
j'avais aussi été secrétaire général de
l'OMC l'organisation mondiale sur le
commerce aujourd'hui coordinateur des
instituts Jacques Delors à Paris Berlin
et Bruxelles entre autres casquettes et
engagement parce qu'elle a mis notre
union qui se dirige au printemps vers de
nouvelles élections européennes mais
dans quel état de santé finalement vous
la voyez pour commencer par un
diagnostic économique
à long terme l'Union européenne a un
problème de croissance économique par
rapport au reste du monde qui tient
d'une paras démographique déclinante
alors que la plupart des autres pays
notamment les pays émergents mais aussi
les États-Unis ont encore une population
qui augmente et puis au fait que c'est
disons 10 ou 20 dernières années elle a
perdu du terrain
dans matière de recherche d'innovation
dans la frontière de la technologie ça
n'est pas irrémédiable mais disons les
solutions à la démographie c'est
davantage d'immigration on sait que
c'est compliqué mais c'est ce que vous
diront tous les économistes en matière
de recherche et développement c'est de
faire davantage ensemble contre européen
pour que ce que nous investissons en
recherche en développement en innovation
soit plus productif ça c'est le long
terme à court terme
la situation économique mondiale n'est
pas bonne la sortie du covid a été
compliquée l'inflation qui en a été un
des produits
qui elle-même nourrissent une partie de
l'inflation beaucoup de pays moins
riches que les autres dans le monde sont
très durement touchés par cette
augmentation des taux d'intérêt et donc
on a une situation économique qui
s'ajoute à des tensions géopolitiques
évidemment cette guerre terrible en
Ukraine la rivalité ici ou américaine et
même et même des rivalités intraquants
si je puis dire comme on va le voir
dans les années qui viennent alors
justement il paraît que que depuis la
guerre en Ukraine le grand Européen que
vous êtes parce qu'elle l'a mis
s'interroge sur la pertinence de l'Union
européenne dans le monde actuel pourquoi
chacun sait que je suis un fervent
partisan de l'intégration européenne
mais j'essaie aussi de rester lucide
d'observer les fêtes les événements et
je sens
peut-être mais que
cette guerre en Ukraine cette agression
russe en Ukraine est une épreuve
redoutable pour l'Union européenne
en tant que projet politique
est-ce que l'Union européenne sortira de
cette épreuve l'OTAN assure la défense
vous dites c'est ça déjà l'OTAN et
leader sur le sur les questions de
défense et sur les questions politiques
l'Union européenne n'en fait pas assez
il y a pas de doute que dans la mesure
où cette guerre se décidera par le sort
des armes
si nous gagnons ce que nous devons faire
en soutenant l'Ukraine c'est c'est
l'automne qui aura les Américains et les
Européens mais l'automne c'est quand
même d'abord les Américains qui auraient
gagné sur le plan politique
l'architecture de sécurité européenne
qui va falloir revoir deux fonds en
comble siéquents cette guerre prend fin
est-ce que c'est l'Union européenne qui
sera la table est-ce que c'est les
Américains est-ce que c'est des Chinois
est-ce que c'est des États membres de
l'Union européenne donc il y a là une
épreuve redoutable j'espère que comme
les crises précédentes la crise
économique de 2008
la crise covid
à chaque fois jusqu'à présent
l'Union européenne est sortie renforcée
de ses crises tout ce qui a choqué nos
vies européens est venu de l'extérieur
les subprimes c'est mieux les États-Unis
le covid c'est venu de Chine l'Ukraine
ça vient de Russie ça dit quelque chose
sur le fait que finalement nous ne
sommes quand même pas assez bon dans la
protection des intérêts des Européens de
leur vie et sur le plan économique sur
le plan social ou sur le plan
environnemental on fait mieux que les
autres mais sur le plan économique et
sur le plan politique c'est pas fini et
puis si on regarde du côté du front en
Ukraine on a l'impression qu'on
s'enfonce dans une guerre un peu longue
est-ce que d'ailleurs les Européens
auront à coeur de tenir moralement
est-ce qu'ils auront aussi les moyens de
faire tenir les Ukrainiens leur envoyant
des armes
je pense que oui je pense que oui je
suis plus inquiet sur la position
américaine et notamment si les
républicains c'est-à-dire monsieur Trump
parce que on sait que le candidat
républicain ce sera monsieur Trump était
réélu président des États-Unis là il y a
une énorme incertitude qui est
d'ailleurs beaucoup plus grande qui est
à six mois il y a six mois quand je
parlais à les amis américains et je leur
disait et à leur Trump il sera pas
candidat et s'il est candidats il sera
pas élus c'est pas ce qu'il me disent
aujourd'hui on est à un an de ces
élections et pour ce qui est de ce qui
influenta la situation militaire sur le
terrain en Ukraine je pense que c'est
l'élection américaine qui sera la plus
importante pour ce qui est de la suite
de l'intégration européenne l'élection
européenne de l'année prochaine sera
très importante au G20 sur le chapitre
économique 300 millionnaires écon
ministre représentant politique dont
Thomas Picoti Bernie Sanders ont adressé
une lettre ouverte à ce G20 appelant à
taxer les personnes les plus riches au
monde on a commencé à taxer les
multinationales à taux de 15%
pour pour l'ensemble du monde mais
est-ce que finalement ben la richesse
personnelle c'est quand même ce qui se
transmet le mieux et presque sans
imposition
il y a quelques années de ça 5-6 ans
j'ai présidé pour la fondation
européenne des parties socialistes un
groupe de travail sur ce que c'est un
programme social-démocrate mondial on
avait fait une liste une quinzaine de
mesures assez simple et dans ces mesures
il y avait la taxation d'un pour cent à
1% des principales fortunes dans le
monde c'est une question de principe
elle se laisseront faire parce qu'elles
ont beaucoup de poids financiers
justement beaucoup d'entre eux
et notamment aux États-Unis
considère qu'effectivement ils doivent
partager une partie de cette immenses
richesse qu'ils ont amassé c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'ils font beaucoup plus
aux États-Unis qu'en Europe en matière
de philanthropie je vois par exemple
la même chose que
c'est là effectivement que la différence
idéologique en quelque sorte mais moi je
suis personnellement partisan d'une
mesure de ce type non pas non pas que ça
rapportera énormément et que ça suffira
régler les problèmes de ce monde l'aide
au développement la lutte contre le
changement climatique mais pour des
raisons principes alors c'est vrai que
Bruxelles mais a mis en place des
nouvelles règles en particulier pour les
5 géants du numérique alphabet Amazon
Apple méta Microsoft ça va changer pas
mal le chinois TikTok aussi le Règlement
sur les marchés numériques qui espèrent
favoriser
l'émergence de startups européennes vous
vous félicitez vous pensez que on mettra
en oeuvre y compris des amendes l'Europe
aura ce courage là elle l'a fait au
titre de la politique de la concurrence
dans le passé
demandait à toutes les grandes
plateformes numériques ce qu'elles en
penses elle le fera encore plus avec ce
qui est maintenant une loi c'est plus du
cas par cas on leur demande de ne pas
continuer à privilégier leur propre
service leur propre base de données pour
continuer à attirer des participants qui
ont été sont des clients parce que tout
ça c'est de la pub
donc je pense que sur ce terrain comment
matière environnementale je continue à
parcourir cette planète du nord au sud
de l'est à l'ouest
l'Europe est identifié comme leader en
matière écologique et en matière de
contrôle des systèmes digitaux c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'effet Bruxelles alors
leader peut-être mais Pascal l'ami vous
étiez je rappelle commissaire vous-même
au commerce et la commissaire européenne
à la concurrence aujourd'hui à la
Danoise market lager a tout de même du
renoncer à la nomination d'une
américaine à ses côtés à la demande
d'ailleurs de la France une polémique
quand même qui a été assez intense
est-ce que vous la jugez justifiée
puisque ça démonte pas ça démontre pas
une certaine naïveté de l'Europe
toujours vis-à-vis des Américains
je ne crois pas beaucoup à la thèse de
la naïveté je sais que je sais qu'elle a
cours je n'aurais pas pris cette
décision
non pas que c'est universitaire et
consultante américaine n'est pas les
qualités qu'il faut s'il s'agit de
recruter quelqu'un en plan mondial elle
allait être tout ce qu'il fallait sur le
plan politique c'est quand même un peu
gonflé
reconnaissons-le de prendre quelqu'un de
nationalité américaine pour aider les
Européens à bon moi j'ai fait ça dans le
temps
aller jusqu'au bout
j'ai eu des gros différents avec les
Américains il m'est arrivé de prendre
des avocats américains contre les
Américains parce que il connaît bien le
système juridique américain à
l'intérieur de l'institution quand même
absolument là je trouve que ça discute
mais politiquement faut quand même avoir
un petit peu derrière pour ne pas voir
que une décision pareille va créer du
renouveau alors l'Union européenne c'est
un ensemble de paix et de stabilité qui
demeure la première destination des
réfugiés qui fuient un monde violent et
guerrier parce qu'elle l'a mis
effectivement un nombre de demandes
d'asile qui pourrait atteindre un
million en 2023 une progression très
très forte et ce qu'on se dirige vers
une nouvelle crise migratoire selon vous
et comment l'Europe doit se comporter
pourquoi est-ce que tous ces demandeurs
d'asile veulent partir de chez eux et
venir en Europe c'est parce que chez eux
ils ne peuvent pas dans un certain cas
survivre pour des raisons dont beaucoup
sont des raisons politiques
plus ce monde va mal plus ce type de
demande va se développer
et il y a aussi le fait que l'Europe
reste pour beaucoup de gens dans le
monde l'endroit où la vie est la moins
dure même par rapport aux États-Unis qui
sont un pays dont la tradition
migratoire si je puis dire et beaucoup
plus forte que la nôtre donc ces
facteurs structurels sont là
être demandeurs d'asile ça ne veut pas
dire comme votre on vient de le voir que
votre demande va être satisfaite en gros
c'est la moitié au cas par cas on
vérifie si telle demandeur d'asile qui
demande à pouvoir rejoindre l'Europe
pour un certain temps
est effectivement fondée à le faire
c'est compliqué il y a forcément par
dessus subjectivité mais
là aussi si on prend le recul
pour des pays qui sont des pays qui
n'ont pas de tradition
d'immigration comme l'Europe à l'inverse
le pays comme les États-Unis le Canada
ou l'Australie qui sont des pays qui ont
une grosse tradition d'immigration
l'Europe reste un espoir et un havre
pour des gens qui sont persécutés dans
leur pays et ça franchement c'est une
valeur européenne
intrinsèque spécifique à l'Europe qu'on
doit absolument maintenir est-ce que la
question migratoire est celle de
l'identité vont être au centre des
prochaines élections européennes de juin
2024 est-ce que d'ailleurs vous croyez à
une montée de l'extrême droite qui
salirait à la droite à la droite
finalement traditionnelle pour
reconstituer une majorité très à droite
alors nous analyses aux instituts
Jacques Delors là Paris berlin-bruxelles
sont concordants d'ailleurs avec avec un
certain nombre d'autres observateurs
ces élections vont probablement à ce
stade
basculer
recomposer les forces politiques au
Parlement européen davantage vers la
droite la droite gagnant et en gros les
écolos perdants et les
sociaux-démocrates un peu aussi encore
que c'est pas sûr beaucoup se jouent sur
le taux de participation selon que les
jeunes vont voter ou non aux élections
européennes le résultat politique sera
différent et la meilleure preuve en est
ce qui s'est passé en 2019 aux dernières
élections européennes où il y a eu une
augmentation du taux de participation à
cause de la participation des jeunes
c'est parce que les jeunes ont voté plus
côté vert côté écologique et il y en a
un certain nombre aussi au centre que le
pacte vert finalement a été le produit
de ces élections européennes quel sera
le produit des prochaines ça dépendra
beaucoup de la participation des jeunes
et notamment et notamment sur la
poursuite
de ces transitions écologiques qui sera
un des thèmes de la campagne entre ceux
qui disent faut aller plus vite et ceux
qui disent il faut ralentir on va trop
vite alors la question migratoire sans
doute fera partie du sujet évidemment
les parties de droite et l'extrême
droite vont essayer d'imposer ça comme
si d'ailleurs comme si d'ailleurs
l'Europe n'avait pas besoin
économiquement pour son futur de
population immigrées contenu de son
propre déclin démographique alors vous
êtes aussi Pascal l'ami le président de
la Commission mondiale sur la réduction
des risques climatiques liés au
dépassement et vous estimez que
finalement ne parviendra pas forcément à
rester sous le seuil des 1,5 degrés donc
il faudra adapter nos infrastructures au
réchauffement pour se résigner en
quelque sorte
non il ne faut pas se réveiller
cette frontière du 1 degré 5 qui résulte
de la grande pareille en 2015 demeure
l'objectif
mais il faut aussi être réaliste les
chances qu'on a dit parvenir sont plus
faibles
aujourd'hui qu'hier et hier 40 hier
pourquoi parce qu'on ne va pas assez
vite et le rapport que je vais rendre
public dans quelques jours à New York
refait le tour de tour sur cette
question on a réuni avec cette
Commission mondiale cette personnalité
du Sud 5 personnalités du Nord nous
réexaminons toutes les options et nous
allons faire des propositions
dont certaines sont assez nouvelles et
font probablement un peu de bruit pour
accélérer
la réduction des émissions
et notamment en se prononçant sur le
problème Nord-Sud parce que on ne peut
pas demander à des pays pauvres de ce
comporter de la même manière que nous en
matière d'émission sur le financement de
la natation sur les technologies de
capture de carbone parce qu'il faudra
bien à supposer qu'on arrête les
émissions ce qu'il faut faire il faudra
bien retirer ce qu'on a collé là-haut
depuis 150 ans et même en
réexaminant les pistes scientifiques
d'un certain nombre d'options de jeux
ingénierie ce qui est un sujet beaucoup
plus compliqué sur lequel on va aussi
faire des propositions merci Pascal ami
d'avoir été notre invité de rentrer
alors vous restez en ce qui vous
concerne sur nos antennes nous
continuons sur le thème des ambitions
climatiques réelles de l'Union
européenne c'est pour notre partie débat
tout de suite
[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre pour notre débat
de rentrée l'été a été chaud la forêt
européenne à brûlé dans des proportions
inégalées les épisodes météorologiques
extrêmes se sont multipliés la réalité
du changement climatique c'est imposé
aux Européens et les mois qui viennent
seront ponctués par de nombreux et vifs
débats sur les ambitions écologiques de
l'Union le clivage entre la droite d'une
part à la gauche et les vers d'autres
parts c'est réaffirmé très fort au
moment du vote d'une loi sur la
biodiversité finalement adoptée alors
l'Europe se veut-elle toujours
championne du climat alors que les
élections européennes se profilent dans
9 mois et de nombreux chefs d'États
européens une dizaine de droites mais
aussi Emmanuel Macron ont appelé à une
pause réglementaire sur les normes
environnementales pour préserver
l'économie la Pologne ultra
conservatrice attaque le pack avec
climat devant la justice dénonçant un
communisme la présidente de la
commission quant à elle Ursula van der
Leyens elle-même
issue des rangs de la droite à choisi un
commissaire à l'action climatique
néerlandais qui interroge sur sa volonté
de mettre en œuvre le pacte vert à
maxima alors pour en parler aujourd'hui
bien de bons observateurs de l'Union
européenne Michel derdevait président de
la Maison de l'Europe de Paris et du
signe tank de confrontation Europe
bonjour confrontation repart à a lancé
le premier septembre une plateforme
collaborative ouverte à tous pour
nourrir le débat sur les différentes
thématiques évoquées pendant les 9 mois
nous séparant des élections européennes
on peut participer au débat en ligne et
ce jusqu'au 1er janvier prochain et puis
avec vous donc en face de vous aussi
Christophe préaux bonjour vous êtes le
directeur de toute l'Europe site de
référence sur les questions européennes
avec des décryptages des politiques des
divers pays européens sur évidemment
plein de thématiques mais aussi une
assistance en cette rentrée sur
l'écologie d'ailleurs est-ce bien
l'année de tous les dangers pour le
climat avec une bataille rangée entre
droite et gauche qui est en train de
s'organiser autour du pacte vert
l'urgence climatique est réelle elle
s'est imposée à nous comme vous l'avez
dit pendant cet été je pense que la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
c'est une ambition clairement affichée
cette commission et une priorité majeure
de d'Ursule avantérienne je pense que ça
le demeure évidemment
néanmoins comme vous l'avez dit on
rentre aussi dans la dernière année de
monture de la commission nous sommes à 9
mois des élections européennes et d'ores
et déjà les jeux politiques
des groupes politiques des partis les
ambitions des uns et des autres sont en
train de se positionner vous savez que
les questions climatiques sont des
questions très segmentante sur lesquels
se cristallise beaucoup de beaucoup de
discussions donc effectivement il y a je
pense aussi un danger que il y ait un
frein sur l'ensemble des règlements et
directives qui est néanmoins ont
beaucoup ont été adoptés depuis 2019 et
la présentation du pacte vert peut-être
qu'on les on les relistera mais la
question est celle-ci effectivement
est-ce que l'urgence climatique face à
leur climatique on sacr peut-être
justement la lutte contre son climatique
sur le l'hôtel du de la réalité
politique
vient de le dire mais on a l'impression
qu'il n'y a plus de consensus autour des
moyens à donner à l'Europe dans la lutte
contre les réchauffements climatiques à
quelques mois des élections européennes
le consensus d'abord il existe au niveau
des experts c'est à dire que ce soit des
experts européens ou les experts
nationaux renvoient au fait que quand on
arrive au canne ouverture c'est à dire
urgence climatique c'est pas un choix
idéologique c'est une réalité à partir
de là l'ambition Christophe Prioul
Rabelais depuis 2019 de l'actuel
Commission européenne elle est inchangée
mais aujourd'hui mais le choix par
exemple d'un commissaire on en parlera
peut-être pour remplacer commissaire qui
se présente aux élections aux Pays-Bas
c'est un choix des Pays-Bas et la
Commission européenne ça vous aura pas
échappé la présidence ne le fait pas ne
le ferez pas si par hasard il passe des
tables du Parlement européen
vice-président vers le commissaire
extraite serait placé sous la
responsabilité de ma recette coïtch qui
vise plein de la Commission européenne
ce commissaire pour savoir justement
pour que nos des spectateurs le
découvrent et moi dans la bulle
bruxelloise en effet Monsieur pacte vert
néerlandais Franz Timmermans attiré sa
révérence son remplaçant potentiel vote
que extra à un pedigree qui déplaît
fortement aux défenseur de
l'environnement des précisions de Sophie
samay
il était le visage de la politique
étrangère néerlandaise mais son nom est
désormais associé à un tout autre
portefeuille dans l'exécutif européen à
47 ans et candidat pour devenir le
prochain commissaire européen à l'action
pour le climat Franz Zimmerman est
rentré au Pays-Bas pour devenir le chef
de fil de l'opposition socialiste et ce
chrétiens démocrate entend bien le
remplacer de l'expérience dans les
domaines de la finance et des affaires
étrangères donc après discussion cette
nomination est judicieuse pourtant son
absence d'expérience en matière de
défense de l'environnement et sont
passés professionnels au sein du groupe
pétrolier Shell font grincer des dents à
Bruxelles l'engagement climatique de
l'ancien ministre n'est pas évident lui
qui lors d'un débat en 2021 critiqué la
gauche écologisteaire landaise pour ses
dogmes et ses parties prises
idéologiques
elle aussi issue du Parti populaire
européen la présidente de la Commission
européenne ourse sous la forme
d'erléanes a confirmé son soutien à
l'issue de leur entrevue du 29 août
dernier mais son candidat doit aussi et
surtout convaincre le Parlement européen
lors d'une audition qui s'annonce
tumultueuse s'il obtient cette précieuse
approbation ou que hookstra représentera
l'Union européenne à la prochaine cop28
à Dubaï en novembre prochain
un sommet majeur sur le climat ce profil
à l'horizon cela nécessitera beaucoup de
diplomaties de diplomaties
internationale et je pense que c'est un
immense privilège de pouvoir y
contribuer
un poste de commissaire au climat très
stratégique en tout cas car les
ambitions énormes écologiques sont au
cœur du clivage gauche-droite qui
s'organise avant les élections
européennes de 2024
Christophe préau que pensait de cette
candidature d'un ancien ministre des
Finances certes pas choisi parc
anderleyen mais qui a été validé en
quelque sorte par elle qui devra passer
maintenant l'épreuve du Parlement
européen c'est quoi c'est une erreur de
casting
c'est pas encore mais en tout cas il est
clair que ça pose au moins deux
questions la première remplacer Franzi
mermons ce qui est un social-démocrate
donc plutôt de gauche par quelqu'un qui
est de droite un chrétien un chrétien
démocrate donc ça crée de les mois à la
fois dans la vie politique néerlandaise
mais aussi au sein du Parlement européen
deuxièmement
fervent défenseur de la cause
environnementale sont pedigés par le
poly même si on peut je pense changer et
évoluer et puis donc au sein du
Parlement européen au sein du Parlement
européen au sein de la Commission
européenne chrétiens démocrate donc il
est rattaché au groupe PPE
donc droite conservatrice mais qui est
aussi le parti de recevoir mais qui en
ce moment comme vous le direz rappeliez
justement
sont plutôt dans l'opposition de
l'ensemble de la marche vers laquelle on
avance pour la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique donc le PPE a
tenté je vais pas dire de s'aborder mais
c'est largement opposé à la loi sur la
sur la restauration de la nature
j'essaye en ce moment aussi d'affaiblir
les positions sur sur l'utilisation des
pesticides donc effectivement ce n'est
pas un fervent défenseur de la cause
environnementale
par exemple Michel derdevé
issu de Chelles est-ce que ça c'est un
problème est-ce que en tout cas ces
symptomatiques des diminutions des
ambitions climatiques de la commission
alors que on s'est fixé quand même pour
objectif de la neutralité carbone en
2050 je pense que si on ne veut pas que
le personnel politique européen soit
uniquement
issu des partis politiques mais qui
viennent aussi de la société civile il y
a pas d'interdit et professionnels et le
raisonnement qui renvoie un passé
professionnel il me semble pas très
productif pour la richesse des profils
dans l'Union Européenne peut profiter
pour le reste il y a un point très
important c'est que les décisions et la
ligne de la Commission européenne elle
est collégiale c'est le collège des 27
commissaires qui arrêtent et donc bien
sûr que la personnalité
il y a un glissement à un moment on voit
bien que pour finaliser les derniers
textes du pacte vert il lui était
peut-être en matière de choix et de
décision RH intéressante d'aller
regarder votre profil mais n'oublions
pas ça cette dimension collégiale c'est
très important parce que la ligne dure
c'est la fin de l'année est claire
depuis 2019 elle a été extrêmement
productive on a parlé tout à l'heure
mais beaucoup de textes ont été adoptés
rien qu'en 2023 on a eu à la fois le
système d'échange de quota démission qui
a été adopté le fond social pour le
climat qui a été adopté au bénéfice de
certains pays de l'Union on en parlera
peut-être tout à l'heure le mécanisme
d'ajustement carbone frontières très
important mais n'avons pas la France
donc les résultats sont là les acquis
sont là elles vont être validées par le
Parlement et alors bien entendu et
notamment à une majorité des deux tiers
dans la commission de l'environnement
qui est extrêmement mobilisé sur ces
questions climatiques et on comprend pas
pourquoi et donc ça veut dire que
l'étape alors
en tout cas les socialistes et
démocrates qui m'ont promis de le
challenger très fortement lorsqu'il se
passera devant devant la commission
Environnement du Parlement et ensuite il
faut effectivement un vote au sein du
Parlement donc par le passé de candidat
commissaire un commissaire pressenti
mais pas un commissaire qui ont été
et donc ça veut dire que oui ça se débat
mais il faut surtout ne pas négliger
l'essentiel l'essentiel c'est que cette
commission pour afficher dans un an un
bilan en matière de d'ambition
climatique à la hauteur des attentes de
beaucoup de repères et alors dans le
même temps il y a une dizaine de chefs
d'État sur 27 qui demande à Bruxelles
une pause environnementale pour tenir
compte des nouvelles réalités
économiques et sociales après notamment
l'attaque de la Russie en Ukraine pour
bien comprendre il est là le tournant
qui explique ce changement de ton dans
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique il y a plus de majorité en
Europe pour appliquer le pacte vert et
c'est la conséquence de
conflit aussi on le ressent tous
ensemble la conséquence de ce conflit on
est aujourd'hui dans l'histoire
immédiate donc on l'a subi vraiment à
travers les prix de l'énergie à travers
l'inflation à travers aussi les
relations internationales et tout ça a
été complètement bousculé on enverra
dans dans l'histoire un peu plus longue
mais effectivement aujourd'hui et comme
on est aussi proche d'élection il faut
quand même le dire chaque gouvernement
chaque pays chaque État joue un petit
peu en fonction de des humeurs de de sa
population et et c'est pour ça que
aujourd'hui
les sujets environnementaux comme on le
disait étant assez clivant entre entre
ce qu'il faudrait faire certains
avançant l'écologie punitive nous on en
veut pas d'autres disons il faut faire
de l'éducation donc effectivement
aujourd'hui
on sent quand même sorte de volonté de
freiner un petit peu et de et et pour la
population même si on évoque à chaque
fois le fait que le réchauffement
climatique c'est une priorité majeure la
priorité pour chacun ça reste le pouvoir
d'achat et et
prenons d'ailleurs l'exemple de la
Pologne si vous le voulez bien
ultra conservatrice la Pologne a droit
et justice au pouvoir
ultra dépendantes des énergies fossiles
60% de son électricité premier
bénéficiaire du Fonds européen pour la
transition juste avec 3,5 milliards
d'euros sur 6 ans que vous mentionnez et
pourtant Varsovie a saisi la Cour de
justice de l'Union européenne pour faire
annuler l'application du Pacte vert oui
alors elle a saisi effectivement la côte
justice avec un argument qui est
l'exigence de l'unanimité mais si toutes
les décisions qui permettent à l'Europe
d'avancer
illimité qu'est-ce que ce sera quand on
sera sur une Europe à 30 ou à 35 ça ne
marchera pas donc on va mettre la
majorité qualifiée qui a été retenue
c'est le bon processus de décision
d'autant plus vis-à-vis d'un pays qui a
été bénéficiaire mais Caroline on est en
Pologne avec des élections le 15 octobre
et donc avec un parti qui est née dans
le milieu rural
[Musique]
il y avait tellement de répercussions
sur le secteur économique industriel et
l'emploi c'est une décision qui aurait
dû être prise à l'unité mais là pour le
coup la jurisprudence au niveau de la
Cour de justice elle est elle est claire
donc il y a il y a aucune chance que la
Pologne obtienne bien de cause ça c'est
certain après ou comme le dit Michel
daredevé il y a des questions politiques
puis après la Pologne elle est assez
coutumière du fait parce qu'il y a
toujours un jeu de je t'aime moi non
plus et puis en même temps Pologne est
en prise aujourd'hui avec des questions
d'État de droit les fonds européens sur
le plan de relance notamment ont été
bloqués ils devraient être débloqué
normalement normalement la rentrée donc
il y a toujours aussi une des jeux un
peu de de d'influence et de et de
chantage mais je vais vraiment ça entre
guillemets et pourtant et c'est presque
contradictoire les efforts fournis par
les 27 portent leurs fruits
l'électricité produite à partir
d'énergie fossile est à son plus bas
niveau au sein de l'Union européenne 33%
niveau historiquement bas en lien aussi
avec ce qu'on observé cet été
c'est-à-dire les diminutions de la
consommation notamment de gaz de manière
extrêmement forte qu'on a perdu entre
l'été 2022 l'été 2023 entre 10 et 12% de
consommation de gaz à Europe donc il y a
des phénomènes lourds qu'on évoque peu
on rêve toujours le plateau de la
balance production mais il y a des
changements qui se font dans le dans le
mix énergétique européen qui sont
extrêmement importants oui oui les
choses les choses évoluent depuis le
début de l'année quand même pour
terminer Christophe préaux 400000
hectares de végétation sont partis en
fumée en Europe le double presque de
l'année précédente l'urgence est
toujours là on l'a ressenti donc cet été
et pourtant certains s'apprêtent à
fermer les yeux sur le réchauffement
alors je pense que les électeurs vont
fermer les yeux d'ailleurs je pense pas
alors des dernières élections
européennes en 2019 donc on l'a vu la
participation a été assez a été plus
élevé notamment des jeunes et on a dit
que c'était la question environnementale
qui avait poussé les gens à aller aux
urnes est-ce que ce sera le cas toujours
là est-ce que ce sera pour des bonnes ou
des mauvaises raisons parce que comme on
le disait tout à l'heure comme j'ai
l'air de le disait la question de la
ruralité aussi on la vit pas de la même
manière dans la ruralité ou dans le dans
les grandes villes la question de la
transition de la transition écologique
donc peut-être que certains et les
agriculteurs aussi se plaignent beaucoup
de ces normes et c'est surnorment qui
est qui les contraignent donc la
question écologique elle elle concerne
tout le monde chacun ira voté en soi
dans ma conscience mais peut-être pas
pour les mêmes raisons et peut-être pas
pour pour ce que ce que l'on imagine je
voulais dire aussi que l'Union
européenne avance c'est sûr elle s'est
fixée aussi des ambitions très très
importantes et notamment à 2030 Michel
on main était si je dis une bêtise mais
c'est dans le mix énergétique européen
42,5% d'énergie renouvelable nous sommes
qu'à 22% aujourd'hui donc dans les 6 ans
qui restent il y a encore des chemins
donc il y a encore du chemin et ce
seront les mots de la fin merci merci à
tous les deux tous les deux d'être venu
sur notre plateau pour parler de cette
question environnementale à quelques
mois des élections européennes merci à
vous d'avoir été en être compagnie et
merci à nos téléspectateurs de nous
avoir suivis restés sur nos deux
antennes l'information continue
[Musique]